okay let's follow up about a couple of
stories from last week uh as many of you
know if you watched last week
uh radical republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene
equated wearing a mask on the floor of
the house of representatives
to how jews were killed during the nazi
holocaust of world war ii
this was a completely outrageous comment
and not even that many republicans
criticized her for it most of them
staying silent
but now she's just denying that she ever
said it she was on the dr
gina prime time program on real
america's voice network
i have no idea what that is either and
she said you know really i wasn't
comparing anything to the holocaust and
it wasn't about masks or
something i don't even understand let's
take a look at it together and see if we
can figure it out
i'm going to continue to fight back
against speaker mask hole
that's what i call speaker pelosi
speaker maskhole in her ridiculous
tyrannical masked policies but the
biggest outrage is people being treated
like second-class citizens
um simply because they refused to to uh
show a past passport a vaccine passport
and i had compared it to to the way the
the horrible way
that um jewish people had been treated
by having to show their papers of who
they are
well without a phone call or a text
message all of a sudden i find out on
the news
that kevin mccarthy um elise stefanik
and
and unfortunately steve scalise had all
condemned
my remarks and in their own own
condemnation
of my remarks they didn't even have it
right what i had said in the first place
they were just uh misstating things i
had said and then also they were just
preaching the the woke media
mobs uh talking points so this is this
is a problem they didn't have to attack
me
nancy pelosi doesn't attack her own and
i think the gop
needs to do better so what was the
message you were trying to convey there
well the message is this we don't need
to have americans treated like
second-class citizens
simply because they don't want to get
the vaccine the vaccine is not even
fda uh certified yet it hasn't been
approved by the fda
but yet we have schools like the
university of virginia
telling their uh students that they
can't return to in-person classes
without getting the vaccine well that's
a violation of their freedoms their
rights and their hipaa rights
uh schools and universities should not
step in
especially when there's uh side effects
being shown with these vaccines
and it's not fda approved and people
have the right to choose
especially young people that are in the
lowest risk group and don't need the
vaccine anyways most of them do not
um freedom is so precious we have to
protect it
uh but we can't allow the democrats and
those in charge
um that think they know better than us
and and think they can control
everything that we try to do in our
daily lives we can't allow them to force
us
into socialism and and having a
tyrannical government
we have to stand up against these
aggressions and it's it's important that
we speak out and do that
and so you do reject the media narrative
or accusation i guess that says you
compared wearing a mask
to the holocaust you say that's that's
untrue that's not at all what you meant
by that
oh it's completely untrue um anyone can
ask david brody he was
he was interviewing me at the time when
i made those statements and i wasn't
even talking about
mass per se it was it was talking about
the mistreatment of being treated like a
second class citizen
and i never said the word holocaust it's
just the same as i never said the words
jewish space lasers but then the media
made that one up too
she is just so gross i mean just really
a disgusting person now of course she
did say it
here are her original comments let's
take a look and you're going to notice
if you're of normal
english proficiency it's really clear
what she's saying
it's really clear what she meant this
woman is mentally ill you know we can
look back in a time in history
where people were told to wear a gold
star and they were definitely
treated like second-class citizens so
much so
that they were put in trains and taken
to gas chambers
in nazi germany and this is exactly the
type of abuse that nancy pelosi is
talking about
so she's claiming i guess that
because in that segment we just watched
she didn't use the word holocaust
that the entire comment really was not
equating mask wearing to what was done
to the jews during the holocaust but
marjorie when you talk about trains
taking jews
to gas chambers in nazi germany
that's the holocaust that that was
during world war ii it's just what it is
using the word holocaust or not doesn't
really make it any different
and it's also extra wacky that just a
few days ago she was defending this
she was doubling down she was saying
yeah i said it and then now she said
that's not actually what i said it's
certainly not what i meant whether she
knows this or not
this is a technique called the fire hose
a falsehood now it's not to be confused
with gas lighting it's related to gas
lighting but it's not exactly gas
lighting
not to be confused with the gish gallop
it's related to the gish gallop but gish
gallop is when you say a bunch of
different things
during a debate particularly when
there's limited time and it makes it
difficult to refute you the fire hose of
falsehood
is where you just claim different things
at different opportunities
trump did this all the time he would
take every position on an issue
over a period of a few days the issue is
china trump would say one thing about
china during a debate
and then he would say something
different about china on fox news the
next day
and then he would tweet something
different about china on day three
and number one it makes it difficult for
us to suss out
what is this person's actual position
what are they actually claiming
um and it also makes people sort of give
up on trying to figure out what the
truth is because it just seems all so
complicated
and then lastly it's also a technique
that increases the likelihood
that anybody can find one of your
positions that you like
trump would do this for example on um i
think this was on abortion
remember when on abortion he i'm
thinking back to 2016
he was asked uh should the woman i'm
against abortion
okay should the woman be punished if she
gets an abortion and he said
well yeah she should and then a lot of
pro-lifers love that
and then the next day he said yeah
actually that's not really what i meant
and so like no matter what your position
is you could find
an instance of trump saying something
that you probably liked and just say
listen he did say that one thing there
so i think i agree with him on this
issue um
this is the sort of this is how you
weaponize
disinformation and if you remember that
quote from trump uh about you can't
believe what you're seeing
um the exact quote was stick with us
don't believe the crap you see from
these people the fake news
what you're seeing and what you're
reading is not what's happening
that is the sort of full conclusion of
the weaponization of disinformation
telling people even your own senses
betray you
just listen to me well what if you're
saying something different every two
days
just listen to me it's a smart strategy
when your voters are so clueless do and
say horrible things
and then pretend they never happened
because it muddies up
the message and that's what marjorie
taylor green is doing they get the info
out to the people they are targeting
but then they do their best to walk it
back and end up suffering no
repercussions
think of it like posting retractions in
a newspaper
that almost nobody notices after your
lead story
has already had the impact you wanted to
have that's what they're doing that's
what marjorie taylor green
either i'm not even saying she's doing
it out of a calculation
but it does work when your constituents
are marjorie taylor green's constituents
one of our sponsors purevpn is giving
you 47 percent off
a one-year plan which comes out to less
than six bucks a month
purevpn makes you anonymous online and
you can trust them they're the only vpn
with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity
is not being logged purevpn keeps you
safe from hackers prevents you from
being spied on by your isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500k
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week for just 99 cents
and you'll get 47 percent off
a one year plan which is less than six
bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman